now let's talk Summer Skin Care Pearl
Skin studio the sponsors of this segment
is back with Summer friendly chemical
peels to keep you smooth and glowing and
beautiful and refreshed right right
right because winter is over in Las
Vegas some are just arrived it is around
the corner yes and winter time skin is
usually flaky dry grayish looking so for
summer time if you want to look glowy to
have that translucent bouncy skin that's
what we want there are chemical peels
that are actually some are friendly okay
normally we don't do chemical peels
during the summer time but they are very
gentle ones that you can do all year
round okay and speaking speaking of
gentle it always surprises me that a
chemical peel is so simple it sounds
intense but it's so simple so explain
what you're doing yeah so it's basically
I go over wow the whole face with
chemicals that's it
as you can see she's not changing in
color she's not screaming right she
looks very relaxed so it might be tingly
you know so the benefits of the chemical
peel during the summer during the summer
is as we said bouncy skin but it
improves the look of pigmentation so the
skin appears brighter more radiant more
hydrated glowing and we want to look
kind of like glow yeah
the sun kiss you know so do you get
results right away it's immediate result
and those Victorious music to our ears
yes great for every skin type and
condition and color okay so everybody's
great again very important to apply
sunscreen yeah absolutely you know
actually now that I have you here
because I have this question yes do you
need to be reapplying sunscreen
throughout the day like every few hours
yeah very important to reapply a lot of
people think oh I applied sunscreen with
my makeup and it's enough every two
three hours needs to be reapplied and
there are dry sunscreens that you can
just brush it on over your makeup
without messing up your makeup you know
that's what you guys do now um is it
important to you know wear sunscreen
with these chemical peels yeah it is
important but you don't have to be like
afraid and be completely in the house
okay laying out is absolutely no for
everything always because laying out on
the sun is not healthy right it's not
good we're seeing some before and afters
now too look at that yeah that's amazing
you see that well of course you see it
you did it you did it yeah okay now
where are you guys located and how can
people you know come in for a
consultation yeah
support the bad chance Sahara Pearl Skin
studio you always can call and consult
with us we're gonna give you an idea
what's the best treatment or chemical
peel for you okay because there are
different ones this particular skin
Medica it's fairly brand new to Pearl
Skin studio okay and amazing results wow
well lucky you lucky you all right thank
you Pearl Skin studio for sponsoring
this segment call 702-525-550
four or visit pearlskinstudio.com for
more there's also a special offer for
you fit BOGO 50 off and save up to 175
dollars when you mention Las Vegas now